we are with atalia Cervantes Talia first
of all congratulations welcome to the
show a pretty tame event so far for you
one loss all the other uh ended in a
draw but finally you're back to 50 how
do you feel right now
um well first of all it's great to be
here finally
um uh I think it's good I think I'm in
good track now that I had my first win
it took maybe too long
but overall I feel like my games have
just been like weirdly solid I don't
know
um and obviously my game against Serena
that was like total total mess I didn't
understand my positions but I'm glad
that at least I I have a win now so
you're feeling good about your shape at
this point in tournament yeah and it's
always nice to win with black so a lot
to look forward to let's look at the the
game what were the critical moments in
your opinion right so
um I had the opening prep but I feel
like maybe she had a prep better the
line that we played specifically is not
the one that I thought she was going to
play it is a very Authority one right
right
I mean I based on her games I thought
she was going to play something slightly
different but yes this is quite
theoretical and you have until night B6
Queen A5 Bishop H6
um takes takes Queen D2 rookie shade F4
and here here I was
um lost so Mary was visible due to them
that I played
um and I don't think it was the right
idea either because I definitely didn't
like the position that I got in the
middle game it felt like later things
were easing a little bit but
um maybe E4 was a little bit too
ambitious it was too ambitious yeah and
honestly
um I thought that after the
complications like after E4
um Shipley can be won and then takes
obviously I think if she takes on the on
D6 directly like after 97 yes then my
position is fine like I'm doing pretty
good my knight goes to E6 and everything
everything looks good
um but obviously she can play for for
more than that and not trade Queens
right so after that I wasn't so sure but
yeah I definitely misplayed it F5 was a
really good move by her I really totally
missed it
um
because if I take choices 934 and Knight
at five yes and that is very very
dangerous night
um he's probably gonna check with you
yeah no I I can't afford to allow that
not looking good for sure
um but you put you found this move King
to f8 which was a very crafty move well
my idea is just to get away as fast as I
can
um and it also opens the possibility for
98 and
um yeah just worst case scenario try and
trade Queen straight
and get out of the way so for example if
takes on G6 in that position I was
thinking to go 98 and that wasn't the
the C1 because I think if I go with the
other one there might be some
um yeah yeah C5 and now if you take take
there's another night hanger
um so the other Knight to E8 Rook to B6
is forced you trade trade then take on
G6 right right how did you assess this m
game
um I didn't love it because my
appointment B7 is still a big problem
and my pieces were very discordinated uh
but okay
there's a lot of fun in the position for
sure
um so she played C5 yeah I definitely
didn't like my position but I was trying
to get back somehow B5 I felt like it
was necessary otherwise the bishop and
C4 is just super strong I don't love it
because in 19496 ideas but
um I mean it just I think it just had to
happen yeah and I think once we got into
more of time trouble
um uh when did you feel like you're
finally getting your own chances in this
game yeah I felt like I had something
but
um so instead of queen queen E4 I was
thinking Queen E5 but we were also
getting a little bit low on time and I
didn't know how to assess this move six
minutes for her 13 minutes for you at
this point right so technically I could
put pressure on her I I guess I just
missed
um what my continuations are because I
thought yes sir something like night two
uh D4 maybe Knight C3 yeah Knight C3 and
then that'd be an idea yes yeah it
sounds like takes and then Knight B3 and
I saw something like this but I didn't
know how to what to think of it right
it's not easy to assess this position
it's like typical Sicilian you just
don't know what's going on
but yeah so after the trade obviously I
felt like I was heading into this and
again not in good shape because the
opponent C6 is very well defended but I
guess just things happened
um the more the game went on here I was
like okay now you're feeling it yeah
yeah once the night lands on e4 now now
I'm okay and I felt like I should be
winning somehow it is um and even if I
couldn't see right away the the correct
continuation
um is like all of her pieces are tied
down yeah right because for example
first I wanted to play
um uh yeah after Knight C1 B3 A3 I
wanted to play Rook C2 but then there's
Rook B4 so uh and yeah I guess it's
still completely winning but I don't
want to allow anything
either
um so yeah because some pieces are so
tied down it just has to be winning in
many ways it's not that clear right
right they they can
um Talia still after that it felt like
you converted quite nicely
congratulations an important victory for
you we're looking forward to see you in
the next few rounds thank you so much
well damn Italia nice to see you in the
studio Italia like this